bonjour à toutes et à tous dans la grave
crise que nous traversons
vous pouvez compter sur l'engagement
sans faille de votre département aux
côtés de toutes celles et de tous ceux
qui sont mobilisés en première ligne
pour vous protéger et pour protéger mes
proches restés à la maison
restez à la maison c'est vital voilà un
mois déjà que l'alsace se bat avec
courage contre ce terrible virus
plus de 600 personnes ont perdu la vie
dans notre département
c'est dramatique des centaines de femmes
sont endeuillées elles ont été touchés
au plus profond de leur être et je veux
leur exprimer nos pensées les plus émues
nous partageons leur peine cette
pandémie a bouleversé nos vies elle a
aussi révélé un formidable élan de
générosité et de solidarité des citoyens
des associations des acteurs économiques
des agents des services publics et des
collectivités locales alsaciennes nos
agents du conseil départemental que je
souhaite remercier très chaleureusement
pour leur engagement mais aussi d'autres
territoires français et de nos voisins
allemands et suisses
merci infiniment à toutes et à tous
ding dong and sunrise ce vendredi avec
le concours de ses partenaires et de la
région le département a distribué plus
de 200 mille masques du gel
hydroalcoolique et des équipements de
protection individuelle au service des
domiciles aux épaves au foyer qui
accueille des personnes en situation de
handicap ainsi qu'aux maisons de
protection de l'enfance nous avons mis
en place une cellule d'accompagnement
pour les personnels des ehpad et nous
nous tenons à leur côté au quotidien
notamment pour trouver des personnels
prêt à venir travailler avec eux renfort
nous avons mobilisé tous nos moyens et
tous nos réseaux
pour obtenir du matériel comme pour
trouver des places dans les hôpitaux
frontaliers pour garantir l'égalité de
tous les collégiens et la continuité
pédagogique
nous mettons près de 1300 appareils
informatiques à disposition des familles
qui n'en ont pas nous donnons accès
gratuitement à la totalité des
collections numériques de la médiathèque
départementale pour soutenir nos acteurs
économiques de proximité
nous avons mobilisé environ 54 millions
d'euros que nous verserons dans le fonds
régional résistance et nous mobilisons
tous nos services et outils
entrepreneurs mais aussi bénévoles
personnels des services de santé de
secours de sécurité enseignants et
professeurs employés en première ligne
dans les entreprises les commerces les
services publics
vous n'êtes pas seuls nous sommes tous
soudés et nous sommes tous mobilisés
nous formons une chaîne de solidarité
une alsace unie et forte pour vaincre
l'épidémie